it's been five years since whatsapp
rolled out end-to-end encryption it was
hailed for allowing people all over the
world to communicate securely and freely
but in tandem with some top western
officials whatsapp instagram and
facebook owner meta is dragging its feet
we're taking our time to get this ride
and we don't plan to finish the global
rollout of end-to-end encryption by
default across all our messaging
services until sometime in 2023 we
believe people shouldn't have to choose
between privacy and safety which is why
we're engaging with privacy and safety
experts civil society and governments to
make sure we get this right technical as
encryption can be it's really about the
very core of how we live our lives today
safe in the knowledge that what you tell
your friend stays with your friend or
does it whilst reaching that confidence
is potentially painful according to the
government it's a price worth paying for
safety online
end-to-end encryption brings further
risks indeed in my view it jeopardizes
the good work that has gone before
messages are already encrypted as
standard
but end-to-end encryption where neither
the platform operator nor law
enforcement can see the content
jeopardizes much of that work in the new
technological era more conversations
than not are online and if nothing is
protected then no conversation is
private so either we communicate face to
face or we surrender to the expectation
there's a third person in your
conversation ease of staying in touch
must not come at the expense of people's
data protection and privacy rights
even whatsapp publicly goes against its
owner meta saying that one shouldn't
sacrifice privacy if the government
demands it whatever the reasoning
governments are demanding companies
build a special key to access private
messages
but once the key to your messages is
created can you guarantee it won't be
copied
are you confident that a hacker or a
foreign spy won't steal it
or that your government won't lose it
once that key opens a back door how do
you know a criminal won't sneak inside
and even if a government keeps the key
safe should we trust them not to
mishandle the messages we send
considering our phones are so often
glued to our hands it's a four inch
keyhole into our entire lives so
understandably people aren't exactly
ecstatic about their messages being read
by others privacy is a big
big thing in this country in this world
everyone's entitled to their own privacy
and i think private messages are part of
that
if it's private and it's it's private to
the person themselves and think they
should remain private if they've got
suspicions i guess so but i don't think
they should be able to rely every text
message
so facebook may have changed its name
but deep public worries over its
platform's lack of privacy aren't going
anywhere we heard from journalist and
commentator chadwick moore he thinks
governments are using safety fears as a
pretext to snoop on your communications
the question comes up is facebook
figuring out a workaround for the
government to be able to spy on your
end-to-end messages or what is this hold
up the company says that they just want
to roll it out perfectly and make sure
everything's in line but they've had
about three years now to work on this
and they're now delaying it even further
the excuse that they need to
intrude on your privacy in order to
protect human life and your safety just
it seems
as as transparent and weak as current
privacy rules are it doesn't seem like
they're being completely honest it just
reeks of them using this excuse for
safety scare everyone they have to read
your private messages they need access
to this stuff or else terrorists are
going to take over america that's
essentially their argument or or
whatever western country you know we
have trillions of trillions of dollars
in in the pentagon and in our
surveillance state and all these other
things and they're making the argument
that if they can't uh snoop in and read
your private messages if you have
encrypted data then then terrorists are
gonna come in and kill everyone um it
doesn't make a lot of sense and it just
seems like they want more control and
more power and more knowledge and
information about their own citizens
you